[Musica]
chissà quante volte avete sentito
paragonare la rete a un far west
un mondo senza regole un mondo dove in
fondo si dice che la parola dell'uomo
della strada valga come quella di un di
una scienziata in realtà le metafore
possono anche portarci fuori strada
perché il mondo del west della frontiera
americana come ci è stato presentato dai
vecchi film in bianco e nero non era in
bianco e nero solo nelle immagini era in
bianco e nero anche nella sceneggiatura
nella storia nella dimensione di valori
che definiva chiaramente ciò che era
giusto e ciò che era sbagliato anche in
modo che poi abbiamo messo in
discussione ma soprattutto c'erano dei
ruoli ben definiti c'era il bandito
c'era lo sceriffo e queste c'erano delle
e c'erano delle soluzioni ai problemi
molto immediate rapide un po come ci
siamo sentiti noi quando dopo un anno in
assedio nei fortini delle nostre case
abbiamo sentito le trombe della
cavalleria che ci annunciava l'arrivo
dei vaccini una soluzione semplice
immediata ma subito ci siamo resi conto
che questo non bastava che dalla
pandemia non potevamo uscire solo perché
noi dei paesi più ricchi
avevamo i vaccini i vaccini devono
arrivare a tutti
solo così possiamo sconfiggere la
pandemia è ancora una volta anche qui è
arrivata una soluzione che sembra
semplice togliamo i brevetti permettiamo
a tutti i paesi del mondo di produrre i
loro vaccini
questo sistema ha funzionato
ci sono delle norme delle clausole nei
trattati internazionali che lo
permettono
e stata una vittoria ottenuta in passato
prima di tutto con i farmaci antivirali
contro hiv
quando l'africa era devastata dall aids
ma allora 39 aziende fecero causa a
nelson mandela perché non accettavano
che la proprietà intellettuale dei loro
farmaci venisse sottratta dai paesi più
poveri
oggi moderna si è impegnata fin dal
momento dell'autorizzazione del suo
vaccino a non rivalersi su nessuno che
provi a ripeterlo quindi in questo caso
non è la proprietà intellettuale il vero
problema nel caso dei farmaci contro
l'epatite c
c'era anche oltre la questione della
proprietà intellettuale un grosso
problema di costi perché questi farmaci
avevano dei prezzi esorbitanti ma anche
qui il vaccino di astra zeneca al
momento è venduto a prezzo di costo
perché i paesi del mondo non lo
producono astra zeneca preso degli
accordi con alcuni grandi produttori di
vaccini come se room institute indiano
come altre aziende messicane brasiliane
perché queste producano i loro vecchi il
suo vaccino ma per farlo ha dovuto
inviare in questi impianti per dei mesi
il suo personale per controllare ogni
passaggio
perché la vera differenza quello che
rende difficile adottare
l'esperienza avuta in passato a questa
situazione è che i vaccini non sono dei
farmaci comuni per fare un vaccino ci
vuole una complessità
ci vuole una tecnologia ci vuole una
capacità molto diversa da quella
necessaria per fare un farmaco infatti
astra zeneca perfino nei suoi impianti
principali ha avuto dei problemi a
ottenere il livello di qualità
eccezionale che era previsto dagli
standard e infatti ha ritardato la
consegna dei suoi vaccini più volte
all'unione europea
in america negli stati uniti un grande
impianto già predisposto in previsione
di una pandemia per un singolo errore
umano ha dovuto gettare 15 milioni di
dosi di vaccino di johnson and johnson
perché se i vaccini non raggiungono gli
standard vengono buttati via
è come avere una ricetta di uno chef
stellato non basta avere la ricetta è
nemmeno l'autorizzazione dello chef a
poterla riprodurre bisogna essere capaci
di farlo ci sono tanti passaggi che
bisogna imparare a fare sotto l'occhio
vigile di qualcuno che già ha avuto
questa esperienza è già lo sa fare
e poi c'è la questione degli ingredienti
in questi piatti ci possono essere degli
ingredienti molto particolari che non
proviamo nel supermercato sotto casa
pensate che il vaccino di pfizer
contiene 280 componenti provenienti da
86 diversi produttori fornitori
distribuiti in tutto il mondo in 19
paesi
immaginate la complessità che richiede
il mettere insieme questi ingredienti
con delle macchine che a loro volta sono
particolari sottoposta a brevetti
prodotte da poche aziende quindi una
grande grandissima complessità ma questa
complessità quanto ci è stata raccontata
nelle settimane scorse nei mesi scorsi
fino a poco tempo fa
quanto c'è stata raccontata pochissimo
perché purtroppo anche la scienza spesso
viene raccontata come un mondo in bianco
e nero un mondo dove ci sono i paladini
della scienza i ciarlatani e in mezzo
non c'è niente
un mondo dove le soluzioni sono facili
basta seguire la scienza ma qui direte
hai portato un esempio che non è un
esempio di comunicazione della scienza
hai parlato di problemi produttivi
industrie diritto internazionale questa
è un'altra cosa non è comunicazione
della scienza
beh quello che dobbiamo capire è che la
complessità riguarda tutto il mondo in
cui viviamo e che la scienza oggi non
può più essere considerata come qualcosa
di distaccato dal resto della società è
intersecata con la società in tanti
aspetti e per capire un problema che
riguarda la scienza come produzione di
un vaccino
occorrono tante competenze all'interno
della scienza per cui ne un virologo né
un epidemiologo da solo può essere in
grado di dare tutte le risposte e anche
al di fuori della scienza perché
occorrono tante competenze diverse e
questo è importante quando poi andiamo a
comunicarla avere sempre presente questa
complessità non significa andare sui
social e pretendere su instagram su
twitter su facebook di spiegare tutti i
dettagli di questa complessità perché
nessuno di noi sa tutto ma nemmeno il
nostro pubblico è tenuto a sapere tutto
dobbiamo semplificare quando raccontiamo
la scienza dobbiamo distillare le nostre
conoscenze ma tenendo sempre sullo
sfondo questa complessità permettendo
alle persone di capire che non gli diamo
queste informazioni ma partendo da
questa complessità e avere sempre
presente questa complessità ci aiuta
anche a avere un po più di umiltà perché
se noi sappiamo che ci sono tante
competenze diverse che coinvolte in un
argomento possiamo anche entrare in
comunicazione con gli altri senza
pretendere di sapere tutto e buffo che
molti di quelli che considerano la rete
un far west
poi sono proprio quelli che scendono in
questa prateria a cacciare le bufale o a
sparare contro i nemici
ecco la rete può essere una cosa diversa
se noi scendiamo in questo rapporto di
comunicazione della scienza non per
insegnare ai
altri ma con l'idea di condividere una
conoscenza che la conoscenza condivisa
possa aiutare tutti e che per una cosa
che so io c'è qualcun altro che ne sa
altre e che una persona che non sa nulla
di scienza può avere una sua esperienza
personale che s è importante penso alle
famiglie che hanno delle malattie
croniche delle malattie importanti al
loro interno c'è un'esperienza che vale
che va condivisa ecco se noi entriamo in
quest'ottica possiamo capire che la
complessità è una ricchezza se parliamo
della metafora del far west
non dobbiamo pensare a un mondo in
bianco e nero come i vecchi film degli
anni 50 ma possiamo pensare a questa
frontiera meravigliosa come a un terreno
di scoperta un terreno che sicuramente
nasconde molti pericoli ma anche
tantissime opportunità
possiamo passare dall'idea del duello
sulla strada polverosa di mezzogiorno di
fuoco all'idea della corsa all oro e
filtrando tanta sabbia di questi
torrenti della rete possiamo trovare
delle pepite veramente preziose